-Là, il y en a des milliers.
-Là, c'est énorme.
-Il n'y a pas que des punaises,
d'ailleurs, si ?
-Là, on n'a rencontré
que de la punaise.
-C'est impressionnant.
Musique intrigante
Ca, j'ai jamais vu
de mes propres yeux.
...
Générique
Bonjour, Bruno Studer,
député de la 3e circonscription
du Bas-Rhin
pour un sujet
sur lequel
je travaille depuis 2018 :
la lutte
contre les punaises de lit.
-En Alsace,
autour de Strasbourg,
on connaît bien la problématique
des punaises de lit,
d'abord parce que c'est une
des régions les plus infestées
de France,
mais aussi parce que
le député Bruno Studer
n'a pas attendu
la véritable psychose des punaises
qui a envahi notre pays cet automne
pour s'intéresser au sujet.
Ce jour-là, il se rend
dans une résidence étudiante
pour savoir si,
cette année,
il y a eu ou non
une recrudescence du phénomène.
-M. Studer, bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Car ici, on suit
le problème de très près.
Avec les allées
et venues d'étudiants,
on connaît bien
les punaises de lit.
-C'est la période de la rentrée
où on a le plus de cas de punaises
parce qu'il y a forcément
des nouveaux arrivants
qui viennent
avec leurs punaises.
-Mais c'est pas nouveau.
-Non, c'est un phénomène régulier.
Les punaises,
c'est structurel
dans une résidence
telle que la nôtre,
puisque, effectivement,
le mode de transmission,
ça va être les bagages.
-Il y a eu
un emballement médiatique
qui semblait correspondre
à une réalité de terrain.
Moi, j'ai dit
que c'était un phénomène
qu'on ne connaissait pas trop.
Vous, par exemple, ici,
plus ou moins de punaises de lit
en 2023 par rapport à 2022 ?
-Alors, non,
moins que l'an dernier.
On a traité 49 chambres
et studios et cette année,
on est pour l'instant à 39.
On devrait finir peut-être,
au grand maximum, à 42-43,
donc on aura
une baisse sensible.
-C'est l'intérêt d'avoir
ces statistiques.
C'est qu'on peut dire qu'ici,
dans le Crous, il n'y a pas plus...
Il y a des endroits
où il y en a plus, d'autres, moins,
et c'est ce qui manque
au niveau national :
on n'a pas d'outils
qui nous permettent
de savoir de quoi on parle.
-Le député vient voir
ce que le Crous a mis en place
pour obtenir
ces bons résultats.
Dès qu'une chambre
a la moindre punaise,
elle est traitée
avec des insecticides dédiés
et l'étudiant doit transporter
toutes ses affaires au sous-sol.
-Ah, la vache !
C'est une vraie chambre froide.
-C'est les mêmes chambres froides
qu'on utilise dans les restos U,
mais là,
vous allez voir...
Alors, bon, forcément,
il fait un peu froid.
Vous voyez, là, on traite,
par exemple, des matelas.
Par le passé,
on jetait les matelas.
Maintenant,
grâce à la chambre froide,
on peut juste traiter
les housses ou les matelas
parce qu'on a la certitude
qu'au bout de trois jours,
les punaises sont mortes.
Ca, c'est les affaires
des étudiants.
Là, c'est une chambre,
deux, trois, quatre.
Là, c'est une valise.
Cinq, six, sept, huit.
Allez, huit.
-Les meubles, où les punaises
aiment se cacher,
ont aussi été
un peu remplacés.
-Dans ce bâtiment, où il y a
essentiellement des chambres,
on avait une literie bois
avec des planches
qui étaient non protégées,
c'est-à-dire que les punaises
pouvaient s'insérer,
donc on remplace au fur et à mesure
par des lits métal
de manière préventive
et ça a plutôt
des bons résultats.
-Bruno Studer souhaiterait
dans sa loi demander
aux personnes qui font du Airbnb
de diffuser
des mesures de précaution
auprès des voyageurs.
-Aujourd'hui, l'angle mort,
c'est les meublés de tourisme.
C'est peut-être là
que la loi a un intérêt,
sur quelles contraintes
on peut faire peser
sur les personnes qui font
du meublé de tourisme,
donc qui voient passer
des dizaines de personnes
dans le même logement
à l'année.
Peut-être là y a-t-il
des obligations d'information,
en tout cas,
à mettre en place.
-Mais avant tout, le député
est persuadé qu'il faudrait compter,
répertorier, cartographier
les cas pour pouvoir agir
et sa loi s'adresse
aux professionnels
plus qu'aux particuliers
en mettant en avant
la détection des punaises,
un secteur qu'il connaît bien.
-Bonjour.
-Ca va ?
-Ca va et vous ?
-Oui. Ca me fait plaisir
de vous voir.
C'est celle que j'avais déjà vue ?
-Oui.
-Elle est pas à la retraite encore ?
-Bientôt. Elle a 9 ans.
-Le député s'active aussi
depuis trois ans
pour que le secteur s'organise
afin d'éviter les acteurs
qui s'improvisent
spécialistes du métier...
...sans être vraiment formés.
-Bonjour. Voilà Suzy, qui va faire
le tour chez vous ce matin,
donc elle est déjà très intéressée.
Elle sait pourquoi elle est là.
Là, on est
sur une suspicion
ce matin. Vous avez présenté
des piqûres.
-Oui, ça fait assez longtemps
et suite à ça,
il n'y avait pas eu
d'autres signes
jusqu'à ce qu'on découvre
une punaise
sur un fauteuil
en pleine journée, un dimanche.
-En 2019,
quand j'ai fait
les 1res réunions
à l'Assemblée,
c'était les balbutiements
de la filière.
On a eu des certifications
pour les entreprises
qui font des traitements
et la filière détection s'organise.
Encore une fois, c'est clé.
La détection, c'est vraiment
la première étape,
surtout sur des phénomènes
assez isolés.
-On y va, Suzy ?
Musique cocasse
...
-Suzy...
-Good girl !
-...trace son chemin
dans l'appartement.
-Ici, ici, ici !
-Dans la chambre des enfants...
-Hop ! Ici !
-...elle ne détecte rien.
-Good girl !
...
-En revanche,
près du lit des parents,
pas de doute.
-Elle m'a fait un marquage.
Elle ne bougeait plus,
elle a montré avec son pif
ou était l'odeur.
Ca veut dire qu'il y a
des punaises de lit vivantes
situées dans la zone
où elle a marqué.
-Une détection qui va coûter
près de 300 euros à la cliente,
sans compter le traitement
s'il en faut un.
Le député aurait bien aimé
que les assurances
puissent rembourser ces frais
et couvrir
les risques punaises de lit,
mais pour le moment, il y a un hic.
-Les assurances, aujourd'hui,
elles nous disent
que pour proposer
des produits d'assurance,
il faut connaître le phénomène
pour savoir
combien on va demander aux assurés
de mettre au pot
par rapport à ce que ça peut
éventuellement coûter.
-OK !
-Finalement,
la cliente s'en sort
avec un traitement assez simple.
-Il y a bien eu un marquage,
donc des punaises de lit vivantes
sont présentes.
Je vous rassure, on est vraiment
sur une infestation naissante
très localisée,
donc ça va être
relativement facile à traiter
si les bons leviers sont actionnés
et les bonnes actions
sont mises en place.
Surtout pas de traitement
chimique vous-même.
Même les packagings
qu'on peut trouver
spécial punaises,
pas d'insecticides vous-même.
Ca n'a pas l'air d'être
votre démarche,
mais tout ce qui va être
traitement du linge,
traitement vapeur, etc,
vous pouvez le faire vous-même.
J'ai déjà beaucoup de particuliers,
sur une infestation comme la vôtre,
qui y sont arrivés en louant
un appareil vapeur ou autre.
On a beaucoup
de plates-formes,
des entreprises, même,
qui commencent à louer.
-J'ai cherché, j'ai pas trouvé
de machine à louer.
-On commence à en avoir.
Je vous donnerai
deux ou trois références,
mais c'est quelque chose que vous,
vous pouvez commencer.
-Alors, pour réellement
mesurer le phénomène,
la proposition de loi
portée par le député alsacien
va imposer aux entreprises
qui interviennent pour la détection
et la désinfection de signaler
les habitations concernées.
Le choix n'a pas été fait
de rendre cela obligatoire
pour les foyers eux-mêmes.
-Qui dit obligation
dit sanctions.
Je n'ai pas envie
de créer une nouvelle amende
pour les gens
qui n'oseraient pas déclarer
et on peut comprendre pourquoi
on peut ne pas vouloir déclarer.
Ca peut avoir un impact
sur sa vie sociale,
au sein de l'immeuble,
mais aussi au-delà.
Je pense que c'est une obligation
qu'il y a à faire peser
sur les entreprises
parce que c'est elles aussi
qui font leur chiffre d'affaires
là-dessus,
donc c'est à elles qu'on peut
faire peser des obligations
et pas sur les particuliers,
qui ont déjà assez de problèmes.
-Mais quand l'infestation
devient invasion,
les traitements peuvent être
très onéreux.
-Bonjour.
-Ca va ?
Ca va bien et vous ?
-On s'attaque aux punaises ?
-On va faire un petit traitement.
-Là, vous savez exactement
où elles sont ?
-Alors, tout se passe
autour du lit, apparemment.
Tout a été ciblé
autour du lit.
-Ce studio a déjà subi
deux traitements chimiques,
mais rien n'y fait,
les punaises sont toujours là.
Même si la journée,
on ne les voit pas,
la chambre est pleine d'indices
de leur passage.
-Donc là, on peut voir
quelques traces
de déjections de la punaise.
Ca, c'est une trace de sang,
une punaise qui a été écrasée.
Donc voilà, ça, c'est du sang,
et donc on peut, on peut...
Ca nous laisse croire
qu'il y a une situation
qui est quand même
déjà assez élevée.
-Aux grands maux,
les grands remèdes.
C'est donc
le traitement thermique
qui a été choisi.
La pièce va être
surchauffée pendant 4 heures,
atteignant les punaises
qui se cachent dans des endroits
les plus inattendus.
-Tout reste en place. Tout va
chauffer au-delà de 60 degrés
et puis, voilà, c'est l'avantage
du traitement par l'air à chaud,
c'est de tout laisser sur place.
-Y compris à l'intérieur
du caisson de volet,
ça va chauffer à 60 ?
-Voilà, tout va chauffer.
-D'accord.
Les photos, ça craint rien ?
-Non. Elles vont courber,
mais elles vont
se remettre après.
Ca va se courber
et ça se remettra
automatiquement.
-D'accord.
-Donc on peut lancer, on est prêts ?
Alors, on y va.
Tac ! Vous allez avoir le brûleur
qui va se mettre en route.
-Comme une chaudière.
-On va l'entendre. C'est ça.
Et donc, là, ça va commencer
à monter en température.
-En une seule fois,
la chaleur va tuer
tous les insectes.
Un traitement exceptionnel
sans les inconvénients
de la chimie
car le locataire va pouvoir
réintégrer son logement
dans quelques heures,
mais un traitement coûteux :
1500 euros
pour ce studio
de moins de 30 mètres carrés.
Pour un appartement standard,
le prix oscille
entre 3000
et 5000 euros...
car les équipements
sont encore rares.
-Il y en a combien en France ?
-Il y a deux machines.
Il y a une machine qui est
dans le sud de la France
avec un confrère qui l'a achetée
en même temps que nous,
la nôtre et bientôt,
une troisième machine.
-C'est quoi, les limites ?
C'est la hauteur,
le nombre d'étages ?
-On peut traiter,
avec cette machine-là,
un logement d'une superficie
d'à peu près 120 mètres carrés.
-Mais pas au 15e
ou au 20e étage.
-On peut monter.
La pompe nous permet de monter
jusqu'au 20e étage
sans aucun problème.
-Si les traitements chimiques
sont deux fois moins cher
que les traitements thermiques,
leur prix reste
tout de même important.
C'est pourquoi Bruno Studer
a demandé au gouvernement
un geste financier.
Le budget de l'Etat
a prévu
5 millions d'euros
pour aider les ménages
les moins aisés
à payer les traitements.
Dans sa loi,
le député propose aussi,
dans des cas extrêmes,
d'élargir les possibilités
des maires de forcer les habitants
à ouvrir
et traiter leur logement
pour éviter
les infestations massives.
-La première chose,
c'est lever le frein financier.
Dans le projet de loi
de finances,
il y a la création de ce fonds
pour les collectivités
auquel les particuliers
peuvent faire appel et après,
c'est une manière de dire :
"On met en place des aides
"et puis, si, malgré tout,
les gens ne veulent pas ouvrir,
"on peut passer
à une autre étape
"plus contraignante,
à la main des maires,
"pour faire ouvrir
les logements."
-A quelques mois de l'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques à Paris,
l'enjeu est important.
En septembre dernier,
de nombreux médias étrangers
s'intéressaient
au sort des touristes
qui pourraient ramener ces punaises
dans leur pays d'origine.
En l'espace de 10 ans,
le nombre d'infestations en France
aurait été multiplié par 10.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...